on New Year's every year that's like the
one time that they can party they get
like two drink tickets it's lit we did
the show and stuff but I realized I was
in the two percent of females and I was
an outside female
I was getting tossed around like these
people were going crazy like just all
these men haven't seen an outside girl
in so long I was literally getting crowd
surfed wow
[Music]
yeah
welcome back to another awesome episode
of the careful boys where we today have
a very special guests obviously the new
hire
his name is Jason also have Miss
Christiana Farina here in the building
foreign
ER choreographer actor extraordinaire I
believe something like that yeah how do
we have this random lady here uh
odd friends with with that guy over
there yay everybody he's wild he's the
best and how do you this random guy and
this random lady get to know each other
well I just want to start the reason I'm
actually here today he texted me and he
was like Hey I told these guys that
you're really funny so can you be on the
podcast which is like really sets the
expectation and we're like I can't wait
for her to make us laugh
that's a lot of pressure I know he's
like I told him you're funny so do a
tight 10 minutes we'll just sit back
yeah now she's gonna think that she has
to be funny which will ruin the funny I
know yeah just be friends a thousand
percent and I also do want to say before
we get into me my stuff is I actually
know you guys I told Ryan this
um my old roommate I lived with this
like male model guy probably the gym
stuff not me not me stop looking at me
like that I know not Anthony but
um he loved watching just kidding news
and it would play on the TV every
morning I had no clue who you guys were
but I'd listen to you every day he's
like he still listens to it so that's
awesome that's tight I wonder if he's
watching that during his Calvin Klein
commercials what was his name Brett
Maverick Brett Maverick yes he's fine
yeah I remember that dude yeah he's fine
Maverick
Maverick dude owner Brett Maverick yeah
he's a he's a nice guy so when you were
like listening you know eavesdropping on
on JK through Brett Maverick such a
[ __ ] funny dude
that better not be his real name dude
that's a stage name even the name is
actually is Maverick that's still a sexy
middle name are you entertained or were
you like this is stupid as [ __ ] who the
[ __ ] is this are these people it took me
a minute but I feel like once I got to
know you guys I was like you're two boys
you know hell yeah I'd wake up I said
what's up on the TV you know hello guys
hello
yeah non-stick I'm happy to be here oh
yeah thank you thank you for coming oh
that's tight I didn't even know that
because like right before the cameras
turned on you're like who the [ __ ] are
these guys
yeah I just made it so how so how did
you how did you meet get connected with
Ryan well
um I met through a mutual friend
um I was kind of talking to this guy a
little bit and they were all in the same
friend group and Ryan and I immediately
just say his name just say his name was
it um
why'd you say jmo it's such a hesitate
I didn't R Kelly
why do you say that kind of hesitance
basically I was hooking up with all
these boys that were all his friends I'm
totally kidding oh [ __ ] they were the
boys
I hung up with the boys too yeah I know
who hasn't hooked up with them what
Eskimo brothers
got a fat butt
okay so you're hooking up with something
and then but what's the hesitance behind
the name there's no hesitance at all oh
okay okay
um so I was hanging out with the boys I
was like these guys are so sick you know
the Quest Crew stuff they're breaking a
lot I'm a dancer I had never done
breaking or anything but they do these
crazy tricks head spins flips and stuff
and I was like I need to learn this
teach me so I'd come to the rehearsals
that's tight would make me do crazy [ __ ]
um what kind of crazy she was like a
guinea pig like you could just tell her
hey do this and she didn't have a scope
of how hard it was and you were telling
her you're like oh it's easy and then
she would just do it do a 2000 yeah
anything anything dude yeah yeah but
don't you need like step Stones you need
like you gotta learn this before you do
this before you do this I think it's the
men I think it's a mental hack of like
telling before she wasn't even walking
yeah yeah it's literally that because
like a little helmet for your head spins
all right a beanie yeah she had a little
spin cap no wrist no wrist guard for
your turtle just hitting it she like
understood body mechanics enough where
it's like he was picking it up to the
point where she fell ass backwards into
a [ __ ] B girl gig remember that oh
yeah my my first real professional job
National Commercial I submitted for like
this under armor breaking commercial and
I booked it what I I hit up and this was
after two weeks of like messing around
with this stuff like I didn't know
anything about it I hit up the voice I
was like you guys I have a couple weeks
you have to teach me everything you know
about breaking so I don't show up to
this job and don't know what I'm doing
and it ended up working out I really
think I got it because tight fasting
because you know this little blonde
white girl comes in is like I can break
and they're like sick
um
I showed up on the job I'm not wrong you
know how b-boys all have names yeah I
show up on the job and they're like so
what's your name I was like Kristen
there's like people in gravity there's
cases of like all these sick names and I
was like ah Kristen
I was like oh beagle Christian that's
cool Kristen with a K yeah I that I mean
my name is with a K so
I didn't belong but I made it happen I
feel like that's how it works like you
fake it and I was just like you said
mental headspace I was so overly
confident when I shouldn't have been and
it actually made it work so yeah a lot
of people he's looking for someone to
fill the spot too that's what they don't
know it's behind the scenes when you're
trying to start a gig or like get it get
something going or like you're trying to
cast or like you're trying to hire
somebody people need people to show up
so it's better to just try it more than
not yeah any gig yeah just show up about
my fake Korean story what what all right
so um
I was at my unit in the military right
third England call they're gonna do this
exercise in Korea and they needed
translators so obviously all the random
white guys were like all right you like
five people you need to come to the
office right now and I'm one of them
okay just the Asians yes they bring us
in there and then uh my friend
automatically books because they know
that he's
um 100 like Korean and any translators
and this is like a very like thorough
process because anytime you go into like
any like specialized base they do crazy
clearances that you could be like top
secret and all this stuff right so you
have to fill out like almost like a
phone book worth of information they
call all your references it's nuts they
have all that info but they don't have
nationality so they did all that on me
right and then and the whole time I'm
just crossing my fingers on my dude my
homie my best friend at the time was
going I was like I want to go this
[ __ ] sick
even though you can't translate dude it
doesn't matter
so so there was uh three of us I don't
know four of us that was supposed to go
four Korean translators supposed to go
one of them dropped out one of them is
my my best friend the other guy is in my
unit I mean in my section and then me
but do they all know that you can't
speak they don't know yet
I got hired to go the whole time I have
like my [ __ ] seabed or on the plane
I'm just like oh [ __ ] this gonna be so
crazy I'm like I'll just letting my
homie I was like Hey like any time that
like they ask a question or whatever and
they need us to translate you just jump
ahead and then based off what you say
I'll fill in the blanks also he knew
them yeah he's my best friend my best
friend yeah like he's he's the guy that
has this tattoo with me oh my God he was
good he would be like oh yeah they need
to like I don't know like let's say move
some missiles or whatever oh yeah the
missiles need to be lumos
we showed up in the for the U.S military
yeah we showed up in the middle of the
night in this [ __ ] uh base and Busan
which is like Southern Korea yeah and
then
um they go hey Park come here we need
you so he might my buddy gets sent
outside right because he has to go
translate over there then another guy
comes in and he goes Quan come here and
I was like oh [ __ ] my friend's not with
me so I walked up to it I was like yes
sir he goes tell me what he's saying
right now and I was like
oh he speaks a way different dialect
than I'm used to oh good oh that's good
dude that dialect is pretty nuts
for real some people Busan like I
cannot understand it's like someone with
a really heavy Australian accent yeah
but you can't understand it so that's
real you can look better
that was the smartest excuse you could
have used really damn it and then I
would have [ __ ] froze dude the whole
time they're like oh man it's
motherfucker's useless I didn't get in
trouble I just got put on like really
shitty duties but I was just using what
was it like watching a graveyard or
something no so they put me almost so
they put me in night shift and I'm just
doing radio checks because like uh
they're doing like this exercise in case
North Korea invades South Korea so they
got to make sure all like communication
is open and clear between like the U.S
and South Korea so like it's so
important yeah you can't mess this up
like I'm like this I'm like um [ __ ] what
are the names the call signs are so
stupid too they're like knife companies
it'd be like
Swiss Rod sword broadsword this is Ginsu
do you read me like I read you uh don't
be like I'll read you loud and clear I'm
like oh okay thank you and I'm just
doing this from 9pm all the till 9 A.M
the whole night but at least you got to
go to Korea for free
did he at least teach you some Korean
words like just Baseline so you could
like pretend yeah like the normal [ __ ]
like [ __ ] sheepsick
at least a war didn't start because of
your mistranslation that would have been
hilarious
Zone they put you in a meeting with Kim
Jong-un and then they're like
Quan tell me what he's saying he's like
I don't understand it he said he wants
to start a war
that [ __ ] you know then glorious
bastard scene maybe I hold up three the
wrong way that [ __ ] Chinese I'm
like oh [ __ ] you ain't even gonna make
it that far you're gonna be the guy
who's like gourlami yeah I know I'm like
[ __ ] first of all how many people do you
feel like in the military are doing dumb
ass [ __ ] like that like pretending like
you know that there's they're being
somewhere they're not supposed to be
very few
great answer
okay my my trust in my faith I'm the
only guy in boot camp that uh so in boot
camp really scared shitless I always
still have like a I wonder what what
happens if like a little party side of
my brain that's a party size yeah so
there's a part where you go and buy
supplies and stuff there's a place that
I saw that you could buy disposable
cameras I'm like dude I gotta take some
pictures of Boogie I was just crazy
they've never seen [ __ ] like this before
so I would like pretend like I had a
stomach ache I gotta go to the hospital
and I would just swing by there real
quick and buy a disposable camera and
then so at night or like whenever like I
feel like uh is a good opportunity where
the drill instructors aren't around I'd
be like
it's not random like little pictures of
boot camp that I probably have never
been seen you're like a spy
[ __ ] big trouble dude I know can they
can they like let's say somebody who's
somebody who does [ __ ] like this gets
hold of this type of footage looks so
you can be like dishonorably discharge
you after the fact no no if I can't hold
you accountable for the [ __ ] up dumb
[ __ ] you did no for legal reasons it's
all fiction for legal reasons it's all
things yeah it's all Fiction it's all
made up it's always Mark's got so many
for real did that during these periods
of his years I understand I relate to
you because I faked the time made it
yeah I am speaking of military stuff uh
you got me booked on the job dancing for
red food oh yeah yeah I did it yeah yeah
so uh red from LMFAO we went out to Abu
Dhabi and we had a show and it was for
the U.S military base out there which is
one of the coolest experience I've ever
had but
it was so fun because they were just two
dancers it was just me and then a guy
really really small and on New Year's
every year that's like the one time that
they can party they get like two drink
tickets it's lit we did the show and
stuff but I realized I was in the two
percent of females and I was an outside
female
I was getting tossed around like these
people were going crazy like just all
these men haven't seen an outside girl
in so long I was literally getting crowd
surfed wow across the freaking out yeah
just partying with me and you were down
for it you're like yeah yeah I have
videos of it I'm on like people's
shoulders I'm like there's guards you
know they got their guns and stuff I'm
like dancing on them oh my gosh it's so
fun so thanks for booking me on hey yeah
I made so many bomb jokes when I was
there because we were with food you made
bomb jokes at the Uso no not at the show
not on the mic but we got that would
have been hilarious just grab somebody
with food
he was making bomb jokes too yeah
we got a tour of the whole base oh like
shine missiles and stuff
there were just so many so there's a
missile out there that exploded a
terrorist camp with your name on it it's
actually terrible that it was it was
being used we signed it
I who asked you to sign it like the
fighter pilot was like can you sign my
missiles it was like a thing yeah
Thomas movies were like the missile
falls but it's a dud but it happens to
be signed by somebody and that person
who still had like their [ __ ] sheep
hurt her family father killed by that
missile drop is like oh Kristen is bum
and he's gonna [ __ ] dedicate the
entire life
total different girl that's it girl
that's wild but that was fun or was it
wild to like possibly think about the
idea that since you were in the two
percent of like girls being thrown
around and crowd surfed by a bunch of
dudes who haven't seen like human flesh
or like females for a long time but they
were looking at you like just straight
meat like did that bother you at all no
I would there was nothing that like went
too far like I understood it and I was
having fun with him because there are
Men of Honor yeah they were cool right
yeah it's not like they were like
translation skills did you feel like the
hottest girl in town oh yeah I was
having the time and you get to choose
the hottest guy that you wanted to damn
wow that must be amazing
not only the hottest guy the hottest 10
guys you wanted to
to marry lawfully to marry me yeah right
that's right really Mary yeah you know
and to if I was the only guy emotional
love and support for an Amazonian
warrior women are there and I'm the only
guy I would have been like dude I'm in
heaven
I feel like moments like that is when
like all the guys are trying to talk to
her and then somewhere in the back a
dude turns around and goes Leave the
Girl Alone
like that's the guy you pick and there's
another guy in the corner that's like
I'm I'm Chinese back yeah just be Korean
or him or him equal chances yeah
either or
oh that's good to know um so you were
also mentioning that you like completely
nearly died because of Ryan what was
that story
particularly because of me it's not
because of Ryan at all
I'm gonna blame it on you okay uh
I said like I am really Fearless like I
do a lot of stuff I love adrenaline
things always doing crazy things he
fears everyone
yeah nobody says this
is another language in Korean in
Japanese in Japanese lots of language
mistakes continue
um yeah so I was on a roof in Miami I
wasn't even like there's not a cool
story to it I wasn't drunk or anything I
was completely sober but my Airbnb had
this rooftop
um where you'd like climb a ladder go up
there it was such a pretty view so I'd
go up there every night I was supposed
to be in Miami for New Year's and
it was Christmas Eve I was up there
hanging out
on the way down coming from this ladder
I fell off this roof 15 feet backwards
on the concrete you just slipped right
yeah
he facetimed me and I was like hello
Ryan popped out of the [ __ ] chimney
and 300 kicked her in the stomach and
said this is Florida
that's exactly what happened yeah I've
just slipped out of nowhere I slipped
out of nowhere you were by yourself uh
there was one other person with me oh
thank goodness went down but he didn't
catch me oh wait like it was it was high
like he just he just saw it happen did
he fall first no yeah he did it he's
already down there yeah and then he's
like you didn't catch me I was kind of
broken arms you know like Home Alone
yeah pretty much uh I broke six bones oh
[ __ ] yeah I I kind of dancers know how
to fall you know and so I knew not to
like hit my head or anything and it was
high enough for me to process it so I
braced it all with my left side broke
six bones dislocated shoulder spray my
back I was in the hospital on Christmas
they were like Merry Christmas like
making all these jokes I'm on morphine
I'm like let's go
um did you um were you unconscious or
were you like
I would I was conscious it like I had
never broken anything before but I
almost like I didn't really feel the
pain at first I was like so jacked up
you know how you kind of like yeah yeah
you're like in shock yeah I was in I was
in shock abs like was it like bones
sticking out and [ __ ] like that like it
was it was just a little bit crooked
especially shocked but you also were
able to process how like [ __ ] up you
were
I didn't I didn't know how it was
actually worse than what I thought I
thought it was kind of just like because
I saw my hand was really messed up my
fingers were different ways but I
actually had like fractures in like the
hand wrists the elbows like like the
point in different directions it just
all crushed um but yeah so I was out of
stuff for you like over a year I was all
casted
um so I couldn't dance and stuff so I
have a little bit more fear I'm not
doing as much crazy stuff as before but
it's called getting older yeah can you
still move like you used to move oh look
at that wow maybe those broken bones
helped you more one of those wow wow
joint angles of your hair yeah I did
look at that [ __ ] right there dude is
that before or after the audition the
breakdancing oh that was way after oh
wait after yeah that was her first one
when you when you were first in doing
entertainment right huh oh yeah yeah
yeah I have a friend in high school
you're very lucky uh because he jumped
off a roof and missed the pool and now
he's paralyzed he missed the pool missed
the pool it's kind of stupid yeah
sorry about your friend
do you want to talk about it oh we're
out of time